welcome to Texas
whenever anything of coming home to
Texas this is what I think of beef ribs
I love these and I am so happy right now
I'm going to finish eating this plate
off-camera I know so many other people
see Texas is either this this or this I
am so happy to be back in the great
state of Texas thank you
GOP country yes Texas is a state that
spent the last few decades solidly in
the red column and in fact out of any
state in the nation Texas voters have
gone the longest without putting a
Democrat in statewide office the state
has also gone for every Republican
presidential candidate since Ronald
Reagan but katooni eighteens be a new
dawn for Texas Democrats I think
everything is on the line everything
that you could possibly care about this
state could be the state that brings
this country together at this divided
moment and some have high hopes for bata
will work to turn Texas blue again you
heard me again hey Pam
I mean ioan and this Sunday we have
traveled to one of my very favorite
places Texas and we're here to find out
the real odds of this state going blue
in 2018 or 2020 so stay with this and
hit that subscribe button right now
because we're going on a journey and I
promise to show you more food so I'm not
sharing this the way
the last time this date had either a
Democratic governor or senator TLC owned
the Billboard charts and now people are
wondering if beta award can break that
streak beta work is a senatorial
candidate who's campaigning on
immigration reform universal health care
and generally not being Ted Cruz Cruz
has low approval ratings and this is the
first time he's even had a serious
Democratic challenger for his seat and I
gotta say pork is unlike any other Texas
politician I've seen in recent years
universal health care comprehensive
justice reform or making sure that every
single woman so could this be the guy
who ends up changing the course of Texas
politics I'd say he has a pretty good
chance of pulling off an upset the
enthusiasm is real high I haven't seen
anything like this in a while
meet political analyst and Espinosa his
bold prediction is that 2018 is the year
or Roarke and other Democrats pull off
upsets unlike anything seen in two
decades Espinosa is a data guy and he
broke down why he thinks it looks so
optimistic for one first time voters in
Texas favorite Democrats by a margin of
5 to 1 in the last election and it
wasn't just in the blue cities it also
happened in the red parts of the states
too and earlier this year in the midterm
primaries Texas Democrats doubled their
turnout rate from 2014 and Republicans
only increase their turnout rate by a
tiny bit I think it's the truth is it's
a real moment happening in Texas right
now and we're seeing it you've seen it
in the primary this year we're seeing it
the activism with the campaign's that
are out there
we're seeing it in the fundraising
numbers we're confident that it's gonna
make a difference in 2018 for the first
time in 30 years every congressional
district even the most Republican has a
Democratic challenger and a handful of
them are actually expected to flip flu
even some that have been GOP strongholds
since the 1960s Texas Dems are also
targeting the Republican State Attorney
General who's currently under indictment
Espinosa says Democrats hopeful outlook
is all because of the changing of Texas
demographics
it's the Latino populations around the
state and that this is a population that
will rise awaken and seize its political
power but what you're also seeing are
other groups from around the state and
it's all these new people moving to
Texas who are saying in themselves wait
a minute I'm a Texan too I can vote I
have a voice I have something to say and
that's what's challenging this
Republican power right now now for those
of you chuckling at the thought of a
blue Texas
guess what Texas used to be a blue state
Ginger Rogers did everything that Fred
Astaire did she just did it backwards in
growing up this woman was my
introduction to Texas politics governor
Ann Richards she was sharp and witty and
she was a Democrat that's right the
governor of Texas from 1991 until 1995
was a Democrat and way before her there
was this guy their cause must be our
cause too because it's not just Negroes
but really it's all of us who must
overcome the crippling legacy of bigotry
and injustice Lyndon Johnson was JFK's
vice presidential pick because he was a
southern Democrat Johnson would go on to
become the president that signed the
Civil Rights Act the Voting Rights Act
and he gave us Medicaid and Medicare
landmark legislation and policies so
that's the Texas I knew growing up but
that was years and several Republican
governors ago so how did Texas lose its
blue streak after the civil rights
movement white Texas Democrats started
to leave their party in droves and they
found a home in the Republican Party
then came the state's economic boom in
the late 1970s and early 1980s
and we begin to see people from out of
state flocked to Texas bringing with
them more conservative ideals and more
stringent religious beliefs and Texas
becomes a haven for those seeking fewer
taxes and less regulation fast-forward
to 1994 when that conservatism made
george w bush governor and the state has
never looked back Texas is ready for a
new generation of leadership since then
state Republicans partisan redistricting
also known as gerrymandering has helped
keep the legislature overwhelmingly
Republican they have been able to hold
on to a state that doesn't necessarily
look like that government but again one
wave election with a lot of
gerrymandering layered in can do a lot
of damage and we're hoping to undo that
in 2018
but many Republicans say that won't be
easy to undo Texas will be red as long
as I'm alive and II Hulk is a
spokesperson for the Travis County
we can party and he thinks while some
districts might flip in November there's
no way better O'Rourke will win the
Texas Senate seat he's still a Democrat
he still supports abortion
he still supports expanding programs and
higher taxes to fulfill the Democratic
agenda and still think he's gonna crack
43% personally hope thinks our work is
nothing more than another flash in the
pan
Texas Democrat that gets a lot of
attention but then fizzles out like the
last Democratic candidate for governor
who ended up losing by 20 points Wendy
Davis now she was a state senator here
in Texas who made national headlines
international headlines even for
supporting abortion rights and that made
her a celebrity but it wasn't enough to
carry her through ultimately I think
it's gonna all boil down to the fact
that people are gonna vote their values
but Espinoza told me something that
could change the way you've been looking
at Texas politics well we like to say as
Texas is not a red state it's a
non-voting state he's right Texas ranks
46th in voter turnout in 2016 only about
half of Texans voted we're volunteers
with the organization called jolt and
we're trying to mobilize the Latino
community to get out and vote so we
wanted to know if we could count on your
pledge to vote so that's where groups
like jolt come in joltin organization
that's trying to get young Latinos to
the polls a group they believe is
crucial for the state to elect Democrats
Texas in general people always think
like Oh white Cowboys right people
riding horses ranchers farmers things
like that but that's not Texas no somos
parte an organization cosima Joel you
know Texas is nearly 40 percent Latin X
and by 2030 we will be the majority in
fact half of everyone under the age of
18 right now is Latin X that's so many
young people who are turning 18 every
day and so if we really had you know
people going out and voting in large
numbers Texas politics would look very
different I think it matters that we're
out here having a good conversation
about it is going to be important for us
as a community we need to come together
and show that we're a powerful force
across especially Texas so could ever
it's like this one
meant like this be an early indication
that Texas is on the move again
and what would that mean for 2020 when
you think of a progressive Texas you
think of a Texas that speaks for the
full diversity of the population that
lives here people who live in different
cities people who look different people
who are of a different age and of a
different race those are voices that
should be represented in everything we
do
but what we have right now too often is
a government that tends to be
adversarial with many populations in the
state that's not representative of a
population that's not representative
government at all if we were to really
change Texas we could change the country
we could change what the outcomes are in
upcoming elections regardless of what
happens in Texas there's one thing we
know to be true there barbecue is
delicious every election cycle I told
you I'd show you more food hey Pam
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to Like share and subscribe as you watch
us how basically a dance off in the
middle of Austin Texas we had an amazing
time on this shoot and we will see you
next Sunday